what's popping pasta Pals it's me Mt and
this is a breakdown of the super dark
episode 4 of Rick and Morty season 7
where Morty discovers the disturbing
very human truth about spaghetti night
and since this episode is very much on
the dark side I just want to give a
Content warning at the top of this video
for anyone who may not be comfortable
with the topic of you know self-induced
dying because this Rick and Morty
episode is all about this though I am
assuming that you probably already
watched the episode and know this
already but you know better safe than
sorry right also spoilers for the movies
never let me go and soilent green coming
in your direction just in case you were
planning on marathoning these two movies
during the weekend for some reason hey I
don't know your life but anyways let us
break this mother dang down shall we and
when the episode starts with Rick
bringing in the spaghetti for the family
summer is texting with an Android user
on her iPhone before smashing her iPhone
against the wall alter dramatically
showing that she would much rather be
eating the spaghetti than texting which
is a big deal for summer because she
loves text but after the family learns
The Dark Secret of where their spaghetti
comes from Rick brings Morty to the
spaghetti's planet of origin and when
they arrive at a morg to taste the
deliciousness of death the clock on the
morg wall reads 3:55 p.m. however when
they arrive at the funeral service for
the guy Lawrence that they just ate the
sign outside the church notes that the
service started around 10: a.m. so
either Rick and Morty flew to a
different part of the planet with a
different time zone to attend this
funeral or that was one really long
moment of silence but before they even
leave the morg for the funer feral Rick
accidentally flashes himself with a
memory wiping device extremely similar
to those found in the Men in Black
franchise with Morty being super annoyed
that Rick accidentally mind wiped
himself again which is apparently a
regular problem with Rick considering
how Rick has done this in the past
during the Morty's mindblowers episode
when summer had to restore Rick's
memories using an emergency protocol
that he left behind for summer just in
case but anyways back to the funeral a
really interesting detail that I noticed
is that it appears that this Lawrence
guy the Sanchez family eight was highly
likely to be the ex-husband of Amber
Maps the woman that we see old man Fred
bunk steal away from her old family
after they reconnect on friendbook which
is of course this planet's version of
Facebook the corpse that Rick is
scooping the spaghetti from at the
beginning of the episode has the same
hairstyle and 5:00 shadow that Amber's
former husband had so the implication
seems to be that this man chose to unive
himself in large part due to him losing
the love of his life Amber but what is
particularly interesting about this
moment is that when Amber goes to say
goodbye to her ex you can see a bandage
wrapped around his waist possibly the
show's way of connecting this ex-husband
to the corpse at the start of the
episode like sort of like foreshadowing
for his life in a way but anyways after
Morty heads home and tells the family
about the source of their favorite
spaghetti Morty heads upstairs for some
cyber sexy time and it's very clear that
the circumstances of the funeral on the
spaghetti planet has definitely got
Mental Health on Morty's mind as he
deliberately chooses a depression genre
of adult entertainment featuring a
family therapist farm girl hey man not
King shaming I've been there before just
kidding only city girls for me but this
is even more hilarious considering that
Morty actually has a family therapist in
Dr Wong so this kind of makes me wonder
if he's ever fantasized about her in
this type of way the hormones of a
teenager man never underestimate him and
when Morty arrives on planet spaghetti
and meets the president of the planet
you can see that the presidential seal
is represented by two angel wings
located on the right in center of her
desk with the flag for the planet being
depicted as a crescent moon with a cloud
in the middle and later when Morty
brings the Sanchez family the good news
of ethically sourced human spaghetti
summer asks Beth to pass her the
parmesian which is of course a nod to
the parmesian universe where everyone
says parmesan like parmesian that the
Sanchez family were forced to move to in
the season premiere of season 6 due to
Dimension c131 being taken over by Mr
fondles it seems like summer hanging out
with the variance of her friends in this
universe has caused her to accept the
popular and incorrect pronunciation of
Parmesan but soon after this Rick comes
in to burst Morty's bubble by revealing
that the spaghetti planet has begun
producing moros which is a parody of
SpaghettiOs which then causes them to
head back to the counterar likee
Spaghetti planet and fly past that
planet's version of the Golden Gate
Bridge a place that unfortunately has a
really high rate of people who jump off
of it every year to end their lives a
similar Trend that the people of the
spaghetti Planet apparently encouraged
by placing spaghetti strainers instead
of safety nets below the the bridge and
when Rick and Morty discussed the radio
music of Planet spaghetti Morty assumes
that they all listen to the artist Ena
but Rick tells him that their radio is
all just the morning Zoo format with
multiple hosts talking back and forth
but without playing any music because
music actually brings joy to people and
they can't have any of that now can they
Joy is bad for business which isn't too
far from our reality then Rick flies up
to a billboard showing us advertisements
for infidelity Island which is a parody
of Love Island Inseparable sisters which
is a parody of conjoined twins
Inseparable in your typical Wildlife
show on the Discovery Channel Rick then
makes a joke about the planet being
bought by the discovery corporation
which is hilarious considering that
that's exactly what happened to the Rick
and Morty show when Discovery acquired
Warner Brothers and later when Morty
begs Rick to help himself the crisis on
the planet Rick initially demands that
Morty could never say no to him again to
which Morty then Compares Rick to the
infamous American cult leader Keith Riri
who is known for co-founding the Nexium
cult and unfortunately using a very
similar you can never say no approach to
a number of women using that very cult a
real piece of that one but the good
news is is that that turd will be
rotting in prison for the rest of his
life due to an unsurvivable 120e
sentence good riddance I hope no one
writes some letters and later after
Rick's clone subjects off themselves or
running away from Rick's clone facility
Rick mentions the movie Never Let Me Go
which is a 2010 dystopian romantic
tragedy about a facility of clones born
and bred for their organs to be
harvested in adulthood starring Kiera
knly Andrew Garfield and Carrie Mulligan
and needless to say it's a major bummer
and uh all the main characters die which
is neat and after this when Rick and
Morty try to mess with some morally gray
areas Rick references the trolley
problem and says that Morty should
confront that moral dilemma head on the
trolley problem is of course the
hypothetical thought experiment that
raises the question of whether to divert
a trolley to save a large number of
people from getting ran over at the cost
of a singular person on the alternate
track being struck dead by that trolley
instead Rick knew that Morty was not
unfeeling enough to be okay with another
living being suffering even if it meant
solving their major problem of math
deaths on a global scale something that
Rick has undoubtedly had to do many
times in his wacky science man career
and after Rick develops his ethically
questionable solution he brands that new
spaghetti as it's people which is a
reference to the 1973 film soent green
which is a movie about a society set in
an alternate 2022 that is feeding their
poor people people a brand of wafers
called soilent Green conveniently not
telling any of them that soilent green
was actually made of people and when the
main character discovers the Dark Truth
by the end of the movie he yells out
silent green is people it's people which
is where Rick got the name from but
anyways when the spaghetti planet people
reject Rick's new spaghetti offerings
real spaghetti and torso's rights
radical activists burst into Rick's
production facility with the torso's
rights leader being clearly modeled
after Sylvester Stallone's John Rambo
with his signature red bandanna and
mullet and later when Rick and Morty go
to convince old man Fred to take the
easy way out you can see pictures of
both Fred and Amber bunks on the wall
including one of them at the Grand
Canyon and another one of them sitting
next to each other on rocking chairs in
their old age like they do in the
Montage as well as a big picture hanging
over Fred's bed of both of them having a
picnic alongside their world's version
of The Manhattan Bridge but anyways
right before Rick activates his
euthanasia machine in his conveniently
prepared euthanasia science facility
that Morty questions he calls what he is
doing the Kittyhawk of the planet's
metaphorical Wright brothers flight with
Kitty Hawk of course being the name of
the plane the wri brothers flew to
Kickstart the aviation advancement of
humanity and when the flashbag Montage
to an acoustic cover of Live Forever by
Oasis starts you can see that Fred's
earliest memories is when he was a baby
eating Jam at the park with his mom
while staring at the high up
architecture of the city a memory that
would serve as the basis for entire life
as he tries to recapture that moment by
attempting to become an architect and
trying to get Amber to replace the role
of his mother on that picnic blanket
real Freudian man and during that
life Montage we see that Fred invented
this world's version of Legos and
submitted his Lego idea to a parody of
Shark Tank which led to his successful
alternate career path but after Fred
Bun's life is played for everyone on the
planet to see everyone gets grossed out
and Rick and Morty head home to eat
their new favorite Salsbury steak dinner
which leads us to a post-credit scene
set in a universe where vacuums replaced
humanoid people and a vacuum version of
Rick Sanchez goes through the same
events that normal Rick does in the
episode but instead of a humanoid
looking Fred bunks vacuum Rick
euthanizes a tree creature that looks a
lot like Groot from the MCU and finally
as the vacuum citizens of the planet
look on in horror at the truth of where
their vacuum bags come from you can see
a store on the side of them called bag
BHA a that sells designer vacuum bags
which clearly seems like this vacuum
world's parody of a Gucci store or some
other popular kind of designer bag store
that I wouldn't know about but I
definitely thought this was a really
goofy and light-hearted way to end such
a ridiculous and dark episode but
anyways that is it for my breakdown to
episode 4 of Rick and Morty season 7
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow Me @ mastertainment
on Twitter if you guys want to see me
tweet some weird but most
importantly follow heavy spoilers here
on YouTube or wherever we are on the
internet so that you can keep up to date
with everything that we're dropping but
anyways I love you guys so much thank
you guys so much for watching and I'll
see you guys later goodbye